zone Europe sur sensation
[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue dans zon Europe un
numéro spécial réalisé en Espagne nous
sommes à Malaga très précisément une
ville d'Andalousie au bord de la
Méditerranée sur la Costa del Sol c'est
l'une des destinations préférées des
jeunes en Erasmus c'est aussi une ville
attractive pour les entreprises et qui
recèlent de trésors culturels
[Musique]
et tout au long de cette émission je
vais aussi vous faire découvrir la ville
impossible de le rater sur le port voici
elkubo le cube le cube le cube le cube
c'est comme ça que l'on surnomme le
Centre Pompidou de Malaga il a ouvert
ses portes en 2015 c'est la première
antenne de l'institution implanté hors
de France et pour en apprendre plus sur
Malaga j'ai rendez-vous avec Yonathan
gomesnsson le directeur de l'Office de
Tourisme
[Musique]
vous êtes le directeur de l'Office de
Tourisme de Malaga Malaga et sino Malaga
est synonyme de Costa del Sol la ville a
un climat méditerranéen très favorable
quels sont les températures moyennes à
Malaga c'est une Malaga mon Malaga est
une ville qui a 320 jours de soleil par
an
et la température
est une ville avec une grande histoire
il reste des vestiges de l'époque
romaine mais aussi de l'époque musulmane
dalandalus ou encore de la Renaissance
toutes ces époques se mélangent dans la
ville nationale
[Musique]
c'est l'une des villes les plus
anciennes d'Europe Malaga à 3000 ans
d'histoire et avant les Romains il y
avait déjà les fondateurs de la ville
les Phéniciens il y a 3000 ans nous
avons plusieurs vestiges phéniciens nous
avons le théâtre romain des palaises et
des châteaux arabes aussi et chrétiens
dans la ville on peut contempler un tas
de patrimoine de toutes ces
civilisations de fait nous avons le même
problème qu'on retrouve en Italie car
nous ne pouvons pas construire car à
chaque fois que nous construisons on
découvre de nouveaux vestiges
Malaga est connu aussi pour être une
station balnéaire en Espagne quelle est
l'importance du tourisme pour la ville
c'est très important nous avons choisi
d'accélérer car la Costa del Sol jusqu'à
Marbella compte de nombreuses plages
ensoleillées notre ville a beaucoup de
place ensoleillées
comme le musée
le numéro 1 à Malaga en Espagne Malaga
est connu aussi pour son festival de
cinéma c'est la grande fête du cinéma
espagnol chaque année ici en espagnol
tous les ans le festival de cinéma de
Malaga est une référence internationale
nous sommes la ville où est né et où vit
Antonio Banderas notre festival année
après année progresse et atteint un
niveau de haute qualité et pas la
terminale et pour finir Malaga est un
dissociable de Pablo Picasso le célèbre
peintre c'est ici qu'il est né c'est une
immense fierté pour les maladies Malaga
nous tout ce qui a un lien avec Picasso
nous le promouvons et nous l'aimons
parce que Picasso et Malaga en plus
l'année prochaine ce sera le 50e
anniversaire de la mort de Picasso et
aussi bien en France qu'à Malaga il y
aura de nombreuses célébrations et
expositions lors de cette année 2023
je rappelle que vous êtes le directeur
de l'Office de Tourisme de Malaga
le point commun entre l'acteur Antonio
Banderas et le peintre Pablo Picasso non
Pablo ne donnez pas l'indice et bien ils
sont tous les deux nés ici à Malaga mais
on va d'abord s'intéresser à Picasso lui
qui disait donnez moi un musée et je le
remplirai vous connaissez forcément
quelques-uns de ces tableaux Garnica
exposé au musée Reina Sofia à Madrid la
femme en pleurs au Tate à Londres ou
bien encore les Demoiselles de Rochefort
exposées à New York et bien comme le
musée Picasso à Barcelone celui de
Malaga abrite aussi une partie de son
œuvre
zone Europe sur sensation
bonjour José lebrero bonjour monsieur
Corentin merci beaucoup de nous
accueillir dans dans le musée Picasso à
Malaga vous êtes le directeur artistique
de de ce musée Pablo Picasso nation
Pablo Picasso
il a passé ses 10 premières années ici à
quoi ressemblait son enfance dans la
ville à la fin du 19e siècle Pablo
Picasso est Malaga
pas très loin d'où nous nous trouvons il
a vécu la fin du 19e siècle à Malaga il
passait par ses rues lui écoutait la
musique que l'on chantait qui se jouait
dans les rues il a été aux arènes et
dans son œuvre nous pouvons voir une
influence de cette culture populaire de
sa vie dans les Russes sur ces
personnages qui proviennent de la ville
aussi nous pouvons reconnaître au
travers de sa trajectoire un intérêt
pour l'espace disons mythique un espace
historique l'espace de toute la vie qui
caractérise cette partie de la
Méditerranée qui est le sud de l'Europe
et Malaga et l'une d'entre elles
chauffent
elle artiste a toujours exprimé le
souhait que son œuvre soit présente dans
sa ville natale Malaga c'est devenu
réalité en 2003 avec l'ouverture de ce
musée
historiquement si nous regardons en bas
nous trouvons des vestiges historiques
phéniens de plus de 2000 ans nous nous
trouvons aussi dans le lieu où la
culture l'art l'économie ce sont
développées dans cette ville
le fait que le musée Picasso de Malaga
il y a maintenant presque 20 ans est
ouvert ses portes dans ce lieu
historique au centre de la ville a
signifié une grande révolution pour
Malaga cela a amené des personnes du
monde entier et à aider à ce que les
maladies s'identifient à l'art à la
culture et à Pablo Picasso
en ce moment et jusqu'à l'année
prochaine en 2023 il y a une exposition
qui s'appelle dialogue avec Picasso que
pouvons-nous
à dialoguer dans ce cas-là c'est notre
collection permanente dédiée
exclusivement à Picasso vous pouvez voir
plus de 600 œuvres de Pablo Picasso elle
va vous aider à échanger avec un enfant
un enfant qui avait beaucoup de talents
artistiques qui est né dans ces rues et
qui est parvenu à devenir l'un des plus
grands artistes de l'histoire de l'art
occidental
c'est un voyage au travers de la vie de
Picasso un voyage dans lequel on peut
partager son intérêt pour expérimenter
en même temps sa sensibilité à
l'histoire de l'art et à l'histoire
culturelle
el Moussa
éducatif quels sont les activités que
vous réalisez pas la même chose pour
nous l'inscription dans le territoire la
connexion avec les citoyens la
contribution à l'inclusion sociale des
plus faibles
l'organisation d'activités pour tous les
publics font partie de notre programme
et de notre philosophie pour cela nous
avons un programme informatique culturel
dans lequel la musique la littérature le
cinéma pour tous les publics sont
toujours présents
et qu'il était éternelle nous pouvons
dire en quelque sorte que le musée a
réalisé son souhaits
[Musique]
notre mission est de diffuser et faire
connaître l'oeuvre d'un artiste qui est
né au 19e siècle et ce que nous visons
c'est qu'en plein 21ème siècle des
personnes de tous les pays de tous les
âges de toutes les origines continuent
de venir voir ce musée pour découvrir le
génie pour venir voir si Picasso était
si extravagant qu'on nous le dit et
surtout à profiter de la qualité
artistique du lait historique qui nous a
laissé pour le futur le futur c'est
aujourd'hui et je crois que ce lundi que
sa volonté d'éternité depuis Casso a été
accompli
merci beaucoup à vous trois célèbre
héros je rappelle que vous êtes le
directeur artistique du musée Picasso à
Malaga
[Musique]
c'est un autre lieu chargé d'histoire
que je vais vous présenter maintenant
voici l'ALCA ça va un palais forteresse
édifié au 11e siècle par les musulmans
et qui est surplombé par le château du
gibral Faro qui lui a été construit au
14e siècle il se trouve sur une montagne
à 130 mètres au-dessus du niveau de la
mer je vous laisse profiter du paysage
et on se retrouve ensuite pour parler
des jeunes en mobilité
[Musique]
et tout tout contestan
sur sensation
voilà Mario
vous êtes la directrice d'internes
expérience à Malaga c'est donc une
agence d'accompagnement de jeunes en
mobilité quel travail avec vous quels
sont les profils des étudiants que vous
accompagnez quel genre de jeunes
viennent à Malaga
nous travaillons avec beaucoup
d’universités des centres de formation
des lycées ou des instituts de plein de
pays européens
la France est notre partenaire principal
mais nous travaillons aussi avec
l'Italie le Royaume-Uni avec la Bulgarie
la Pologne avec une grande partie de
l'Union européenne
nous avons d'ailleurs rencontré Chloé
elle vient de Villeneuve-la-Garenne dans
les Hauts-de-Seine et ça fait un mois et
demi qu'elle fait son stage à Malaga en
Erasmus grâce à la Maison de l'Europe
des Yvelines on la retrouve tout de
suite elle fait son stage dans une
boutique à Malaga pourquoi avoir fait
une mobilité alors moi j'ai
choisi
et
je l'ai mis à rien faire du coup je me
suis dit pourquoi pas faire un stage à
l'étranger puisque comme je fais des
études de communication c'est vrai que
c'est super important d'avoir
d'expérience un peu à l'étranger et
comme j'ai jamais pu j'ai jamais eu
l'occasion de préparer ou de faire un
stage autre part qu'en France je me suis
dit que je vais profiter de cette année
là pour venir à Malaga et j'ai choisi
Malaga puisque j'avais le choix entre
l'Irlande et Malaga il me semble enfin
l'Irlande et l'Espagne et c'est vrai que
le cadre et la période c'était mieux de
venir à Malaga sous le soleil donc j'ai
choisi malade en quoi cette expérience
va-t-elle vous servir déjà le fait que
je vienne ici pour trois mois ça va
beaucoup développer mes compétences
linguistiques du coup je pense que pour
mes prochaines expériences ce serait
très important que ce soit l'anglais ou
l'espagnol puisque du coup comme je suis
un peu plus novice en espagnol j'utilise
beaucoup l'anglais ici ça a beaucoup me
servir je pense dans la vie de tous les
jours et même pour mes prochaines
professions
quel est votre quotidien c'est vrai que
quand il y a un stage du coup ça me
prend toute la journée donc j'essaie de
sortir plutôt le soir et sinon les
week-ends je me réveille enfin tout
pareil qu'en France c'est juste que
directement je sors directement à la
plage parce que c'est vrai que moi en
France j'habite en Île-de-France du coup
il y a pas de plage à côté ici il fait
tout le temps chaud du coup je vais
directement à la plage ensuite je vais
un peu me balader je fais souvent des
excursions aussi parce qu'il y a une
agence ici qui s'occupe des étrangers
donc je fais souvent des excursions pour
découvrir les villes d'à côté comme
Séville ou grenade ou grenade on dit en
français Granada en espagnol et oui je
fais c'est comme ça que je passe mon
temps ici que dire aux jeunes pour les
convaincre de faire une mobilité je
conseille très fortement puisque c'est
vraiment une expérience unique on n'a
pas la chance de venir ici tout le temps
que ce soit en famille d'accueil ou en
stage ici tout se passe très bien tout
le monde est très gentil on vous
accueille vraiment chaleureusement les
Espagnols ils sont vraiment super sympas
et trois mois pour ma part c'est c'est
vrai que c'est un peu court mais c'est
suffisant pour vraiment découvrir une
nouvelle culture et vraiment s'amuser en
même temps aussi
étudiants certains viennent pour faire
des stages en entreprise comme Chloé
quel secteur recherche des étudiants
étrangers en stage ici
nous avons des étudiants en formation
dans le domaine du commerce de
l'administration nous en avons en
mécanique nous avons un panel assez
vaste avec presque tous les secteurs du
marketing cela dépend principalement des
étudiants car nous cherchons des
entreprises qui s'adaptent aux études
alors un exemple d'entreprise tout de
suite nous on retrouve Maria del Mar
RIMENEZ qui est la maître de stage de
Chloé
je fais ça car j'ai des enfants de l'âge
les étudiants et parce que ça Yaris
panaquer la directrice m'a contacté je
pense que nous devons avoir une bonne
image aux yeux de tous pour l'Europe
pour la France surtout pour nos voisins
ici on travaille très bien nous sommes
des gens travailleurs j'apprécie l'envie
qu'ils ont et l'attitude aussi j'aime
beaucoup
j'essaie de lui apprendre à être
constante elle doit être travailleuse
elle doit soigner son attitude comme on
travaille ici dans cette boutique on
travaille comme ça partout mais
peut-être que je suis plus sérieuse
l'eau normale
elle doit être rigoureuse sur les
horaires cela lui montre ce qu'est
finalement la vie au travail ce qui est
normal dans les lois espagnol évidemment
et je suis très heureuse de l'avoir ici
de recevoir des étudiants c'est un peu
comme mes enfants je leur fais confiance
et pour moi l'attitude est vraiment
fondamentale s'il n'y a pas une envie
d'apprendre d'enseigner car on s'apprend
mutuellement s'il n'y a pas cela le
travail ne sert à rien j'essaye enfin de
leur faire profiter un peu de ce qu'est
Malaga je suis très contente ok
il y a la possibilité d'être dans une
résidence étudiante comme ici mais les
étudiants peuvent aussi être avec des
familles espagnoles comment ces familles
sont-elles sélectionnées
nous faisons des recherches pour les
familles familiales
depuis très longtemps car Malaga est
connu dans le monde entier quand il
s'agit du tourisme linguistique donc les
familles ont beaucoup d'expérience
évidemment avec ma collègue nous faisons
des visites pour vérifier que tout est
en ordre les fenêtres la chambre qu'ils
aient un bureau qu'il fasse bien à
manger afin de nous assurer que la
qualité que l'on offre est bonne
nous avons également rencontré Marisa
qui nous parle de son expérience ça fait
10 ans qu'elle fait famille d'accueil
ici à Malaga
c'est un peu comme si je voyageais avec
les étudiants
j'adore cette expérience car cela me
fait découvrir d'autres pays d'une
certaine manière d'autres cultures
et je le vis très bien
il y a de tout je ne vais pas vous
mentir il y a des étudiants qui quand
ils s'en vont nous pleurons beaucoup et
puis il y en a d'autres on leur ouvre la
porte et on leur dit adieu mais il y a
des étudiants qui sont incroyables c'est
devenu comme mes enfants et en même
temps il m'appelle mamie je leur fais ma
tortilla avec mes pommes de terre des
plats typiques de ma terre
car je ne suis pas malaguen je suis de
Galice les empanadas s'ils adorent ça je
leur fais un peu de tout du Pisto des
rayonnens
j'ai de très bons souvenirs de beaucoup
d'enfants quand ils entrent c'est vrai
qu'il faut fixer des règles basiques
certains les acceptent d'autres non mais
en général nous créons des liens
spéciaux
je n'ai pas de préférence entre les
garçons et les filles pour moi ils sont
tous pareils
j'ai reçu à peu près tous les âges de 12
à 54 ans et je les traite tous pareils
par la terminale c'est pas ça
aujourd'hui pour finir il y a une
cérémonie avec des étudiants portugaises
à quoi ça sert ce genre de cérémonie
cérémonie
à chaque fois que nous avons des groupes
nous faisons un événement final dans
lequel nous remettons des certificats
ces certificats signifient qu'ils ont
accompli cette épreuve qui est très
difficile de venir dans un pays étranger
de parler une autre langue c'est pour
nous un moment où nous leur disons
félicitations tu es venu en Espagne tu
vas retourner dans ton pays enrichi par
cette expérience de travail
à Malaga une expérience Erasmus peut
parfois changer une vie ou offrir en
tout cas un début de carrière nous avons
rendez-vous avec Stéphane il a 23 ans
après un premier stage ici en Erasmus il
a décidé de revenir on le retrouve à la
plage c'est le lieu de rendez-vous par
excellence après le travail
[Musique]
salut Stéphane hello merci d'être avec
nous alors toi tu as fait un premier
stage en 2021 à Malaga comment ça s'est
passé exactement donc moi j'ai fait un
stage à Malaga en janvier en février
début février
j'étais en pleine année de césure je
savais pas quoi faire et en effet je
voulais déjà amener m'améliorer en
anglais de vagin c'est partir en Irlande
au final on m'a proposé Malaga
qui a été un très bon choix pour moi je
suis passé du coup par une agence
intermédiaire ici sur place qui m'a
proposé un stage en tant qu'assistant de
communication marketing donc ça pendant
trois mois c'est le stage
c'est très très bien passé j'ai fait
énormément de choses le poste était très
polyvalent et je me suis vraiment très
très pris et donc tu as eu l'opportunité
de poursuivre ce stage avec un emploi
fixe ici tu as pas hésité à revenir ah
faut pas hésiter à revenir je suis là
depuis février maintenant ça fait cinq
mois et je suis très content d'avoir
fait ce choix alors quels sont les
atouts de Malaga par rapport à la France
qu'est-ce qui t'a donné envie de revenir
déjà le climat la population
moi mon bien-être aussi parce que je
vois la différence par rapport à la
France je suis très heureux et j'aime ce
que je fais et ouais les avantages c'est
plus ça et est-ce que tu aimerais
poursuivre cette expérience pour le
futur là pour l'instant tu es tu as ton
contrat mais est-ce que dans les
prochaines années tu dois encore ici à
Malaga pourquoi pas pour l'instant ouais
j'ai une belle projection sur quelques
années après moi me connaissant j'aime
le changement pourquoi pas pourquoi pas
dans une autre ville d'Espagne en tout
cas la Malaga pour l'instant ça me fait
énormément et je pense rester quelques
années de plus merci beaucoup merci
beaucoup Stéphane de rien avec nous bah
avec plaisir aussi Malaga est connu pour
être la capitale culturelle de
l'Andalousie c'est indéniable d'ailleurs
on l'a vu depuis le début de cette
émission mais les actions en faveur du
développement économique de la ville se
multiplie également et les entreprises
françaises peuvent saisir leur chance
avant la pandémie le PIB de l'Andalousie
atteignait les 160 milliards d'euros
c'est la troisième région économique
d'Espagne
[Musique]
sur sensation
bonjour à Leandro Hernandez de Castillo
bonjour
de commerce et d'industrie
franco-espagnole ici à Malaga tenemo
Sona nous avons l'image de l'économie
andalouse comme étant en retrait par
rapport à celle de Catalogne ou de la
région de Madrid quelles sont les points
forts de l'économie andalouse de la
économie
en espagnol c'est mieux car nous sommes
en Espagne sur la terre de Malaga et je
crois que la question que vous formulez
en réalité c'est un cliché car cela
était vrai dans le passé aujourd'hui
certainement pas
l'économie andalouse est une économie
très positive très forte très proactive
et avec des secteurs très dynamiques
comme le tourisme évidemment mais je
précise aussi qu'il y a par exemple le
secteur des nouvelles technologies a
l'air digital vraiment pas loin vous
avez ici à malag le parc technologique
d'Andalousie qui regroupe à un tas
d'entreprises et plus de 30 000 emplois
plus de 800 entreprises certaines
d'ailleurs sont d'origine française qui
travaillent dans le secteur de
l'économie digitale et aujourd'hui
l'économie digitale et le tourisme avec
la culture sont les secteurs
déterminants de l'économie andalouse en
général et celle de Malaga en
particulier quoi quels sont les
entreprises françaises installées ici
installadasaki
franco-espagnole nous leur donnons des
précisions nous les aidons à s'installer
pour celles qui veulent
s'internationaliser et s'implanter en
Espagne de la même manière que nous
pouvons aider des entreprises espagnoles
ou andalouse pour faire affaire en
France dans le cas de l'Andalousie je
m'en occupe conjointement avec mon
collègue à Séville de la partie
andalouse occidentale moi je suis de la
partie orientale et nous avons beaucoup
d'intérêt nous observons ces derniers
temps qu'il y a beaucoup d'intérêt des
jeunes entreprises françaises des jeunes
entrepreneurs et je crois que la qualité
de vie est beaucoup si vous en doutiez
encore Malaga et la Costa del Sol est
l'un des meilleurs lieux du monde et je
dis bien du monde je crois que je ne me
trompe pas pour vivre et Malaga mais à
côté de ça nous avons aussi à Malaga des
entreprises françaises connues qui ont
choisi cette ville et certaines ont leur
siège social comme entreprise Pernod
Ricard spécialisée dans la distribution
d'alcool qui associer pas la Malaga et
nous avons aussi des délégations
d'autres entreprises françaises dans le
domaine surtout du consulting de la
digitalisation et de l'informatique qui
ont choisi de mettre leur siège à Malaga
pour leurs affaires il y a la
multinationale américaine Oracle qui est
dans le parc technologique avec plus de
600 ingénieurs nous avons une entreprise
de service numérique française à tous
qui vient de gagner un concours avec un
ordinateur capable de faire
314000 milliards de calculs par seconde
cela va être énormément
utile dans le secteur de la santé pour
découvrir de nouveaux médicaments de
nouveaux vaccins prévenir les pandémies
comme celle que nous avons connues ces
derniers temps nous avons aussi un
Malaga des entreprises dans le secteur
des eaux comme par exemple Veolia une
multinationale française que nous
connaissons tous je la vois beaucoup
soutenir le tennis je suis un grand fan
de tennis et je regarde tout le temps
Roland-Garros et d'autres tournois que
Veolia soutient toujours une entreprise
qui plus de 20 milliards d'euros à sa
délégation à Malaga et surtout je
parlerai d'une autre entreprise plus
jeune mais qui a débarqué à Malaga sous
cette impulsion le groupe
idek qui fait du consulting sur
l'organisation des espaces de la
logistique et aussi de la digitalisation
c'est devenu un acteur très important
d'un projet emblématique en Andalousie
et aussi en Espagne qui est Puerto Seko
des antéra qui va permettre que tout le
commerce maritime
d'Algésiras et de Malaga auront une base
à entéquera un port sec et de la
distribueront les produits à toute
l'Europe le groupe
ideck soutient aussi le sport avec la
Nautica un trimaran fantastique sorti il
y a peu à Malaga ils ont aussi une
équipe pour les 24 Heures du Mans et
puis le PDG Patrice adore Malaga je
crois que c'est une très bonne idée
qu'il ait cette terre
devenir s'installer en Andalousie
je crois que beaucoup d'entreprises par
le passé sont venus avec des clics
exclusivement fiscales pour économiser
les coûts je pense qu'aujourd'hui Slide
est passé aujourd'hui elles viennent
pour d'autres raisons
la sécurité juridique assurée par la
communauté autonome d'Andalousie avec le
gouvernement que nous avons et qui nous
donne une grande sécurité juridique le
gouvernement andalou a décidé récemment
d'aider toutes les entreprises en
diminuant les demandes administratives
c'est plus simple on est dans les jeunes
entrepreneurs ensuite les coûts de
fonctionnement logement ou électricité
ne sont pas aussi chers que dans
d'autres régions et surtout c'est
quelque chose qui avec la crise
économique qui arrive que personne ne
pourra de l'enlever c'est la qualité de
vie le soleil que nous avons ici sur ces
terres qui s'appellent la côte du soleil
et c'est très important aussi
et pour finir comment la CCI accompagne
les entrepreneurs français ici
c'est notre travail
depuis la CCI on est dans les
entrepreneurs surtout de cette zone qui
veulent faire à faire en France
aujourd'hui si on regarde nous n'avons
plus de distance entre nos territoires
nous avons la chance d'avoir un port
international avec des communications
avec le monde entier les vols aussi
chaque jour il y en a qui vont en France
dans plusieurs villes Lyon Marseille
évidemment Paris Bordeaux aussi
nous avons aussi le TGV qui nous relie à
2h15 quasiment de la capitale Madrid
comme on nous les aidons
en étudiant leur inclusion dans le
marché français soit en créant une
filiale là-bas ou en les mettant en
contact avec une entreprise française
avec qui ils peuvent faire affaire cela
peut aussi être une fusion ou une
acquisition d'entreprises pour s'établir
là-bas d'une autre manière nous aidons
aussi les entreprises françaises à
s'installer ici il faut être nous
connaissons leurs idées et leurs
objectifs nous les accompagnons dans
toute la procédure pour créer la forme
juridique adéquate une société anonyme
ou une société à responsabilité limitée
par exemple merci beaucoup merci
Hernandez del Castillo je rappelle que
vous êtes donc le délégué territorial de
la CCI ici à Malaga économie culture
tourisme et même gastronomie on approche
de la fin de cette émission on va passer
en revue les atouts de Malaga et ses
projets à venir j'ai rendez-vous avec
Jacobo florido Gomes le maire adjoint en
charge du tourisme
zone Europe sur sensation et on retrouve
à présent Jacobo florido Gomez bonjour
bonjour à tous vous êtes le maire
adjoint de Malaga en charge du tourisme
Malaga espun des villes les plus
d'Espagne quels sont vos projets ici
pour continuer à développer le touriste
c'est plus d'un million 400000 touristes
que nous avons reçu en 2019
l'ensemble de la province a reçu en 2019
donc avant la pandémie 19 millions de
touristes et ce que la capitale de
Malaga tente d'être c'est une porte
d'entrée culturelle le tourisme culturel
mélanger au tourisme gastronomique et
bien évidemment le soleil et la plage
ce triptyque pour le nommer comme cela
fait qu'aujourd'hui Malaga est devenu
une ville très attractive que les
touristes veulent découvrir et l'offre
un peu de tout loisirs culture tradition
le soleil et la plage nous avons vu dans
cette émission que Malaga est devenu la
capitale culturelle de l'Andalousie ces
dernières années le nombre de musées a
beaucoup augmenté cette évolution
va-t-elle se poursuivre
et ça évolution
après Madrid et la ville culturelle de
l'Espagne c'est le cycle le plus visité
ils ont culturel les visites culturelles
ici nous avons plus de 30 musées en
premier lieu le musée de Malaga le musée
carmencien ou aussi la réplique de l'un
des musées les plus importants le Centre
Pompidou qui a son siège ici à Malaga
cela était un pari réussi qui a augmenté
le nombre de touristes mais aussi le
niveau de la dépense moyenne qui est
importante
et de la durée du séjour et bien
évidemment nous sommes en train
d'étudier les possibilités pour attirer
d'autres références culturelles vous le
savez nous avons aussi le musée russe de
Saint-Pétersbourg mais pour les raisons
que tout le monde connaît nous avons dû
reporter suspendre
ça a été un succès une fois les
expositions lancées mais si des
professionnels culturels souhaitent
venir à Malaga bien sûr que nous les
écouterons avec beaucoup d'attention
et moi ça
nous avons appris aussi dans cette
émission que l'économie malagane ne se
concentre pas seulement sur le tourisme
mais il y a aussi le secteur des
nouvelles technologies ici qui commence
à avoir de l'impact
[Musique]
internationales se sont implantées à
Malaga comme centre névralgique
technologique du sud de l'Europe et bien
au-delà
et toi résultat Malaga a fait le pari de
miser sur le monde technologique déjà
depuis des années 80 on a eu cette
concentration du secteur technologique
qui est en train de s'amplifier ce sont
de nombreuses marques entreprises
internationales qui sont en train de
s'installer ici avec leur centre
nevralgique à Malaga
nous ne pouvons pas mettre tous nos œufs
dans le même panier il faut trouver un
équilibre et ici vous trouverez du
tourisme de la culture et la technologie
c'est notre principal Paris pour que
Malaga soit une ville innovante
normalement
c'est la gastronomie et c'est restaurant
on mange très bien ici
la tradition gastronomique andalouse et
à Malaga a toujours été très forte
actualiser les recettes de nos aïeux et
faire de la grande cuisine
de la gastronomie contemporaine
et comme je l'ai dit notre épicentre
dans la gastronomie
merci beaucoup mouchage gracias
je rappelle que vous êtes le maire
adjoint de Malaga en charge du tourisme
et on ne peut pas se quitter sans parler
des spécialités locales je vous emmène
dans l'une des tavernes les plus
célèbres de Malaga et pimpy l'acteur
Antonio Banderas qui a notamment joué
Zorro au cinéma et mais tellement cet
endroit qu'il en est devenu l'un des
propriétaires
[Musique]
zone Europe sur sensation
nous sommes maintenant avec prosecobos
bonjour bonjour
ici vous êtes donc le fils du fondateur
de la bodega el pinpi et donc
aujourd'hui copropriétaire de ce
restaurant puis mets la première
question
quand les premiers bateaux de touristes
sont arrivés au port de Malaga
du bateau il y avait des locaux qui les
aidaient pour visiter ce qu'il
souhaitait les touristes voulaient aller
au musée il les accompagne au musée ils
cherchait une maison ou un restaurant
tout ce que peut vouloir un homme ou une
femme quand il va quelque part
bien manger profiter danser et le soir
draguer les femmes ou des hommes
et bien ces personnes les guidaient dans
Malaga ils les aiguillaient et ces
personnes les touristes les appelaient
los pimpis
a ouvert en 1971 c'est devenu
aujourd'hui l'un des restaurants les
plus célèbres de Malaga comment
explique-t-on ce succès
voilà
considération des habitants de Malaga
qui l'ont toujours considéré comme leur
maison
une maison dans laquelle on reçoit des
amis la famille ceux qui viennent
visiter Malaga beaucoup d'habitants les
envoient ici comme si c'était un musée
que tout le monde doit connaître d'abord
il y a ça ensuite nous avons souhaité à
partir d'un restaurant faire comme si
ici était le berceau de la culture des
traditions de l'Espagne et de Malaga
réunir la culture il est traditions avec
la gastronomie je pense que cela est la
clé de notre succès et avoir de la
nourriture et des boissons populaires
rien d'extraordinaire pour ne pas que
les prix explosent tout ici et populaire
quels sont vos spécialités
c'est le jambon au châtaigne
vous pouvez le voir derrière
mais au lieu de manger des glands au
moment de la période des châtaignes il
mange des châtaignes et nous en avons la
production totale à Malaga personne
d'autre ne le distribuent c'est notre
produit star à partir
nous avons le poisson frit typique de
Malaga les bokrison le plus frais que
nous avons et tous les légumes nous les
cultivons depuis notre potager c'est un
potager écologique qui approvisionne une
grande partie de notre carte
[Musique]
merci beaucoup merci beaucoup prose
d'avoir été avec nous je rappelle que
vous êtes le fils du fondateur de la
bodega el Pimpi à Malaga et maintenant
vous m'avez donné faim on va passer à la
dégustation
[Musique]
zone Europe à Malaga c'est terminé pour
aujourd'hui vous pouvez retrouver cette
émission en replay sur notre site
internet sur notre application et sur
notre chaîne YouTube radio sensation et
aussi sur TV 78 nous on se retrouve la
semaine prochaine pour un nouveau numéro
très bonne soirée à tous salut
[Musique]